Michael's in California hey Michael
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
thank you so much for having me on I
appreciate it absolutely how can I help
so me my wife just got married last
month it was actually a month yesterday
and she had a car that she was driving
because she was at home and her dad paid
for it made the payments on it well he
just talked to her today and is asking
her to make the payments on it now and I
knew I should have talked to him about
this before we got married I don't want
to take on any more debt but the issue
is I know I had spoken with my wife
season before we got married and I said
I would have been willing to make those
payments on the car once we got married
but we want to be debt-free we have
$1,000 in emergency funds ready go in
days she driving the car yes correct she
is right in the car okay and it's in his
name the card in his name the loan is in
his name okay tell him thank you for the
offer no we want to sell the car so
don't make any more don't make any
payments on it don't so wait because no
I don't want to take over these payments
and no you shouldn't have to pay the
payments but I were getting out of that
we don't want to get further into debt
and taking on the responsibility these
payments is like me going in by a car on
car payments while I'm trying to get out
of debt and so I mean I'm not a car on
debt yeah I'm not going to do that and
so and we understand that that this you
know this is what happened up until this
point but as of today we're married and
you're asking us to take them over and
our answer is no we don't want to so
let's get let's work together and let's
get this car sold and so the original
deal before you got married
was he bought his daughter a car in his
name letting her use it and who was
paying the payments then he was correct
okay and so that was the original deal
and the only difference is you've gotten
married and he wants you to
over the payments which is reasonable
request right right okay yeah but but
what I'm trying to think through here is
the is if the car is upside down
I guess he owes that money yeah I don't
know if the car is or not have to look
at the Kelley Blue Book value and what
he owes on it now that I don't know how
expensive a vehicle is it it's a 2010
Honda Civic so my guess is it's worth
anywhere between five and seven thousand
or something like that
and what are you if you were to guess
what's out on it um I did see paperwork
on it before we got married because I
was still curious about it at the time I
think it was a little over five grand
okay so maybe it's not upside down it
might not be no okay good that's good
news because I don't want him to get
hurt with this he just bought his car
bought his daughter a car it's in his
name he paid the payments and now he's
going to sell the car and the deals over
he's not hurt right and you don't take
over the payments and you're not hurt
the only issue is my wife might be hurt
not having her car but I have my car
that I don't drive every day for work
because I have a work vehicle so she can
drive that car and you guys can save up
some money right quick and buy her a car
with cash yeah that's what I'm thinking
so what's your household income with her
need probably about I'd say between 85
90 a year the other thing you could do
save about five grand in the next three
months and pay it off and just take the
Honda yeah if he's willing to work with
us on that but why would he would never
work with you to pay off the car he's
asking you to pay payments on oh I see
what you're saying I get it yeah you
just pay it off as if it were your car
let's pretend let's pretend you married
her and she had a $5,000 car debt and
you make eighty five thousand and you
pay that off in three months right
that's not a big deal yeah that does
change the discussion a little bit
somehow I had in my head this twenty
five thousand dollar car dad and you
guys made a sixty grand or something so
ratios are a little different eighty
five to five how much weight and you
don't have any debt does she have any
that oh no I I have dead oh you do have
dad what are you how much does yeah
that's the that's the issue so I have I
have around myself 54,000 31,000 his
student loans 19 is on a car and then I
have about 3,500 on a stupid 401k loan
that I did stupidly ok I'm probably
gonna change my answer now that I've got
a better picture I was going on
principle and I was assuming the wrong
numbers no I would not be forced
boundary wise to take over these
payments as an obligation okay I get
your stance on that but this number is
so stinking small relative to your card
debt or relative to your income that I
probably would just say hey yeah we'll
take it but be ready to get the title
because I'm getting ready pay it off and
put it early in your debt snowball and
pound that sucker it's a $5,000 car it's
not a bad idea
maybe sell your car but instead of
handing hers back but that's another way
of looking at it I'm probably going to
just take care of this and that way you
don't have to create a family issue
either but it is a boundary violation
the way this went down I agree with you